امل عرفه 25 سؤال لازم تجاوب عليهم بسرعه
ومن غير تفكير لو رجع فيك الزمن ايش تغير
في حياتك ولا شيء
كل نفس الشيء بعيده لان اي شيء عملته انا
بزمن سابق او بعمر معين فهو نتيجه الوعي
بهذا الكلام اغنيه بتعبر عن حياتك
كثير تعبانه
يبدو اجا للانترفيو بهذاك الوقت بزمن هيك
شويه نشاز فجوبت بتسرع هذا اللي قالت لي
اياه يعني بس انا برد انه ديما ديما شقفه
من قلبي يعني اوكي طيب ايش استفدتي من
التجربه التقديم البرامج استفدت كثير لانه
تعجبتني تقديم البرامج لم تقتصر فقط على
برنامج في امل من سنتين بالتسعينات قدمت
برامج على الام بي سي وقدمت على الارضي
وقدمت على كثير محطات برامج اطفال
همم
نافذه ثانيه لك يعني انا بالاساس ممثله بس
لما بلاقي برنامج حلو مهم كمان بتحبني لما
بلاقي اغنيه حلوه
ولما بلاقي فكره كويسه بتحبني
بس انا اكيد اكيد اكيد
عمل قدمتيه الاسباب كنت
ضائقه ماديه صعب قولوا لانه بيجرح الناس
اللي يشتغلوا فيه اوكي
فقط لا غير تعطيني سنين السنين
السنين كانت بانكم يعني بدك تقولي بين اي
شيء قبل ال 2017 انا عندي غير بعد 2017
بالسنه اللي فاتت فيها والدي والسنه اللي
صار عندي همم هذا همم
اوكي تمام
مو بس مسلسل يللي قمت بالشراكل بالانتاج
والانقاذ مشروعي فقط لا غير يعني دخلت ليس
رغبه مني يعني همم
شو كان السؤال انه ايش السبب اللي فشل هذه
التجربه من وجهه نظرك ما فشلت التجربه
العمل ما نعرضت كفايه ما اخذ وقته كثير
همم اعتقد انه اذا فشل ولا اذا نجح
كلياتنا بنتحمل المسؤوليه هيك بجوز يكون
سوء اختيار بجوز يكون همم تسرع بمنطقه
معينه او من ناحيه معينه
وهو اذا كان
اوكي يعني مش مشكله طيب ليش بتعبر عن رفض
التعملي فكره الزواج مره اخرى والله ما
بعرف
ما بعرف يعني
الله ولا فالك ليه
بحس انه
انا حدا قدري كثير وحقيقه انا مسلمه امري
الى الله يعني
مدوره على شخص احبه ولا مرتبط فيه ولا
اتجوز ولا عيد مره ثانيه بقدر ما انا
عايشه حاله سلام عندي ستايل لحياتي عايشته
ومبسوطه فيك كثر خير الله مع بناتي يعني
هنلون الاولويه بالحياه حياتي
يضيف سلام لهذا السلام اوكي
بابا اسماعيل اي كلمات مديح باذنك يطلعيها
من اذنك هاي لانه ما بدهم لحدا انت شو بدك
من هذه المهنه اصلا انك همم فن ولا رساله
ولا احترام من الناس ولا محبه ولا ولا
تحديد الاولويات الاساسيه
[موسيقى]
يعني
بس لا اكثر خير الله الحمد لله الحمد لله
ايش احلى شيء في عمر الخمسين
انك بتعرفي حالك تمام اااه بتحسي انه
بتعرفي كيف تسعدي نفسك
بتعرفي شو بدك من الحياه وشو الحياه
بتعرفي تماما كيف دائره الناس اللي انت
بتعرفيهم خلص انت مكتفيه ما يعني يلي بده
يدخل جديد بده يكون كثير
مش كثير يستاهل اوكي ما عاد في بيصير عندك
قناعه انه انا قداحه اعيش لسه اذا انا
بالخمسين
عشر سنين ثاني
ليش ما بنشوفك في اعمال الدرامل المشتركه
السوريه واللبنانيه لان ما صار طلب جريئه
هذول الاعمال فقط ينعملوا على مبدا نجم
سوري
همم انا عملت مع جورج خباز
اسمه جراندو الشرق وانا اصلا بدبي هون بس
انت بتحسي بشكل عام انه يعني دائما هي
الممثله تكون لبنانيه وهو سوري ولو جت
نجمه سوريه ثانيه فلازم تكون سنيده في
العمل ما بحس وهاد الحقيقه اممم هذه
الحقيقه تقريبا طيب دور صانع اسمك
سمر بهالي خمس نجوم الجوارح همم العلقاء
بالجواهر طلعوا بنفس السنه هادول
وبعده نستمرت الاعمال كمان في خان الحرير
بالجزء الاول والثاني الغجريه مع هيثم حقي
همم الجوارح مع نشدات الزهور مع هشام
شربات الله
بتعبر عن ارائك السياسيه بصراحه هل خسرك
هذا الشيء انا ما عبرت انا رئيس السياسيه
على فكره
السياسيه
واللي بيهمني من كل شيء بالدنيا انه بلدي
تبقى بخير
يبقى بخير
بس ما عبرتي عن رايك في الازمه السوريه
يعني همم
قرروا اشياء ثانيه يعني
بغضب معين من الناس في وقت حساس
يمكن الناس بتحسب انه فلان مع هون وفلان
مع هون انا
مع البلد نفسها مع اي شيء بصير لمصلحه
البلد
وشايفه قديش الناس
لسه ما امنه انه هذا البلد حيوقف على حاله
اوكي
بالاضاءه بالصوت
[موسيقى]
كان عندي لما يكون ضيف عندي شويه همم
ايقاع وهيك على الهدا فكنت حمسه
شد ايقاع كثير لدرجه انه ببعض المرات قطعت
وهذا منيح همم ما عم بقول لك انه كان لازم
ينعمل مثلا خمس ست حلقات هذا اللي طلبته
انا وبعدين همم نوقف ونشوف شو العيوب
وبعدين نكمله نصلح نكمل بعد التصليح وساده
ما صار هل الرجال دمهم اخف من النساء
وعشان كده عدد الكوميديانت من الرجال اكثر
لا ابدا ههه
لا بس هي جابت العادي انه صعب يكون فيكم
يعني همم ممثله وبنسرق تكون جميله رغم انه
في كثير في كثير ممثلات كسروا هذه القاعده
كان بمصر سوريا
طيب لو تختصر انفصالك عن النجم عبد المنعم
عمايري بكلمه ايش بتكون قدر الله وما شاء
فعل
جدا جدا جدا وهي نجمه كمان سوريا
فاخبار من 2014 انا لحد الان انا ما بفتح
نشره اخبار العلميه ابدا يعني بسمع هيك
همم عناوين قصص بس اني انا اشوف مشاهد عنف
او مشاهد هاي انا ما ما الحقيقه ما قدرت
اتحمل وعملت لي اذى نفسي شديد شاني شان
كثار من السوريين لكن انا هلا بعتبر انه
انا بنت بنت الشعب السوري بيصرف النظر هذا
السوري شو موقفه سياسي
طلعوني وقفوني على رجليه وحبوني ودعموني
وانا عندي استعداد
انسانيه همم
لكن الانسانيه لا تتجزا واعتذاري انا
مسؤوله عنه وبعده لهلا موجود على صفحتي
بالتواصل الاجتماعي رغم انه كلفني كثير
لانه ولا احد رضي يكتب شيء لا من الجهه
المنتج بوقتها ولا من الكاتب ولا من
الممثلين ولا حاجه كنت انا وحدي وحسيت انه
ممنوع ما
بتقول هذول الكلمتين دول تتمنى اداءه او
كتابته دور اتمنى ايه همم هلا عم بشتغل
على شيء بس صعب احكي عن الموضوع
شخصيه
طيب بناتك سلمى ومريم ايش اخذوا منك وايش
اخذوا من والدهم الفنان عبد المنعم عمايره
سلمى الكبيره اخده من ابوها ال ااه ما
بعرف اذا المفرده صح ولا لا
الشيطان هيك يعني
فهي بتقدر تهريب حاله وبعدين بتيجي بتحكي
لي اوكي اوكي
[موسيقى]
لا نسبه لعمره همم
بحس انه عندها حكمه اكبر من عمره
فاعتقد انه اخذ مني همم وعبد طبعا حكيم
لكن هو شوي انفعالي اكثر مني
بس الحضور اخذينه من عبد المنعم يعني مش
من لا مني ومنه ومنه طيب لو عرض عليك
المشاركه في مسلسلته هل كنت هتوافقي
المسلسل انعرض يعني
انا كمان عم بصور
كثير المسلسل
يكون المسلسل مع مين كان ما ما فت بتفاصيل
اوكي لو طلبت منك تختاري مشهد واحد من
تاريخك تعتبريه الاصعب اي مشاكل تختاري
همم
كثار المشاعر الصعبه اللي عملتها بحياتي
اللي هي هيك ماستر يعني بتعتبر همم
[موسيقى]
اصعب مشهد كان بيموتي همم ثلاثيه موطني
اللي بتحكي عن
اللجوء عبر البحر
كنا نحنا وانا مو عن حالي بس عم بحكي هلا
كنا نحنا الممثلين نصور البحر
اااه لسعات طويله
فكنا نقول انه اذا نحن تصويره هيك كيف اذا
حقيقه يعني
طيب اختاري اغنيه واخذيها لشخص معين
باختار
[موسيقى]
وحياه قلبي وافراحه لعبد الحليم
سلمى
بس انا واثقه انه هي راح تعمل شيء هيك
قلبها من جوا يفرح ان شاء الله يخلي لكم
يا رب
وتفرحي فيهم ان شاء الله شكرا يا امل